- Heidi, you recently posted a throwback
to your first Victoria Secret show.
So what do you remember about it?
Or do you remember about it?
(Winnie whoops)
Cause it's gotta be chaotic.
- Well, I mean, I should've
worn a matching set
when I was rehearsing at home.
(Winnie laughs)
I'm thinking, I mean yeah look,
I put the carpet to the side.
- Oh my god.
- This was a railroad apartment
that I had in New York
and I just wanted to see what
it looks like when I walk,
because also at that time
we didn't film ourselves
as much as we do now with our phones.
So I just wanted to
see what it looks like.
I didn't want to be on one
of the biggest runways ever,
for me, and you know, not
know what it looks like.
So I walked in my heels up and
down that railroad apartment,
to just, you know, till
I got used to being--
- It's like rehearsing,
like we do with music,
like on the stage.
- Yeah exactly.
- Yeah, absolutely.
Did you ever rehearse,
do you do rehearse or
do anything like that?
- I used to rehearse a lot.
I used to watch a lot of, like,
Heidi's videos, Naomi
Campbell and just like--
- You came out of my womb with heels on
(Winnie laughs)
and you were like
"I know how it's done."
(laughter)
- No, cause-- like it
was never something that
my family was into, or you know like
fashion, modeling, anything.
So when I realized that it
was an opportunity for me,
I was like, "Okay, anything
you're going to do in life,
you gotta do it well so you gotta study,
you gotta practice."
- People don't realize how hard it is.
I went to one fashion thing
and it was amazing because--
I love all those colors by the way.
But it was amazing because this girl,
I mean, she was-- they dress you so fast.
- [Heidi] Yeah.
- [Winnie] Oh my gosh.
- It's like a pit stop at Formula 1.
You come on and it's like (mimics a drill)
They rip the thing off your head
the wings come on and
shove you out the door.
- They didn't do her face--
- My quick change, like
literally so nervous.
And they just like didn't
care. They were like--
- They're already calling you.
- Yeah.
- They're already like
(Winnie and Heidi scream)
- No, but you have to
trust those people a lot
because this girl came out
in like a gladiator type
tie and they didn't do it tight enough.
And they fell and caught in her heel
and she fell in front-- and
I was like "Oh my gosh."
Like, and that wasn't her.
It was just somebody, you
know, they were going so fast.
And I was like "That's--
this is a gladiator."
So I was like "That's hard."